first of all it's understanding that
there is an issue and man also should be
part of the solution if it's not your
problem then you could be part of the
solution and you should be part of the
solution
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today i'm with anna radulovsky founder
and ceo of women tech network anna is a
mother an award-winning entrepreneur and
advocate for diversity and tech she is
also the founder of women tech network
and pallicate connecting diverse
professionals with companies that put
diversity and inclusion first
as a regional director at the silicon
valley based founder institute anna
helps founders to start and launch
impactful
companies anna radalovsky welcome to 20
minute leaders thank you so much for
joining me today it's really nice to
meet you anna the work that you're doing
to empower
female entrepreneurs and female leaders
is incredible you're the co-founder and
of multiple organizations and i'm going
to let you talk about that in just a
minute but but i want to i want to
understand before we get into women tech
and and and the different things that
you're involved with you know what is it
about you know female
leadership and female entrepreneurship
that really got you hooked initially on
this mission to empower women worldwide
to go into these fields and take
leadership positions all right that's a
really good a really good question
and when i
think about it the very first time i
think when i started to notice
the things that caused me to
motivate it and provoked me to get to
dive deep into the problem when i
started to find myself to be one of the
few women at tech conference this bit
like a small meet up or like a really
big conference and i was like what's
going on here where are all the women
aren't they actually interested in like
tech and coding and there are so many
roles within tech industry right so and
i just like and even when we you know we
we see a different um tag big events
that women are speaking and then they
just like you know go into the crowd
like when it used to be right now of
course many many many events or majority
of the events are virtual and um they
are often like uh really um
not really not really not really
even um people don't think that they
actually can code you know and that is
like sustaining so how does an engineer
should look like so you think okay this
is actually the girls that can do that
so that's actually the guy that can do
that and different things and i just
started to become really interested in
the problem and i think that's many
founders because i'm also a part of
founder institute which is the largest
preset exploration program in the world
so many founders uh
make often this mistake when they become
passionate not with the problem but with
the solution that's why it's very hard
for them to pivot you know to start
building something else because they
think the product is really cool and
this is gonna work and this must work
because i really love this product but
in the reality you need to fall in love
with a problem to try to find different
solutions okay this doesn't work okay
this doesn't work this doesn't work
should i try this you know so you really
want to make sure that you want to solve
the problem
very very cool and and anna you you
found it to organizations and i'd love
to do sort of a deep dive with you into
those two and both hear the founding
story stemming from the need and to the
great to the great milestones that
you've achieved in both and and then you
know i'm trying to uncover what you
learned from each of them in their own
respective domains the first one
coding girls that you founded you know
almost five years ago
starting with the workshop and turning
it into more that with more than 5000
members what was that about back in yeah
that's a really good question so i you
know i started to do some research and i
found out that uh let's say our
interests are really shaping in the in
when we are young you know when uh when
a boy receives a car and they call him
brave and a girl receives a dress and
they call her nice and cute you know
and well i'm as a mother actually trying
to diversify that i'm really like
against buying my two-year-old kitchen
and i'm just like okay let's buy your
lego let's go buy her more puzzles so i
really want to make sure that we are not
uh you know just uh we are not limiting
her you know i want to diversify
different experiences that she has
and i want to make sure that um you know
because it's sometimes very hot when you
just walk into the store you can see all
this stuff that kind of pink and catchy
well my actual daughter is not super
interested in the dolls
so yeah i think i'm i'm taking a little
bit away the focus of the
of the problem and the things that they
started so i you know sorry just like i
talked to my colleague and i told her
let's organize a workshop and and just
you know for girls to see if they're
interested in coding i shared the
problem she actually could relate
because she uh she's a developer and she
said yeah well actually that's true what
you're sharing let's do it she got like
super excited about that and then we
even ended up organizing two workshops
instead of initially planned and we did
a real course and everything like just
you know was going really well like
girls who were excited and then can you
take me back to that
first workshop what was that like well i
was very excited actually i so while my
colleague was doing a scratch workshop
uh i was having a discussion with
parents and i tried to understand you
know um how what do they think you know
what
do they think that coding is for their
girls why did they bring their child do
they understand the value of it so and
there were parents both mothers and
fathers who some of them were already
intact and they really understood the
value of it you know that early on and
some of them share the girls actually
interested in coding so in another room
there was a workshop so girls are like
getting excited about all it you know
they just like when they walked out the
room they're like mother i want to show
you something what i did like i just you
know on the laptop of course but like
and and then like they were super
excited they really were eager to share
with the parents
it meant that they didn't have a problem
like okay this is not for girls but of
course the the girls were like aged from
7 to
11 i think
no this is like before they become
teenagers before they search for role
models
but it's also critical in this age not
to lose the moment you know to kind of
already uh shape in a more kind of
i don't know like somewhat defined by
somewhat uh
in the society like kind of what do you
what is your daughter interested in how
do you make sure that you bring
different diverse experiences not to
really limit uh the focus of the
development
at what point in this program in in
coding girls did you decide that you
know you're going to scale this so
that's always a question that i'm
interested in you know you you've done a
workshop you've done two workshops you
see that it's working when was the point
where you said you know what we're going
all out we want to really get this in
front of thousands of people and not
dozens of people actually people came to
me and they saw that we were doing the
cool stuff so people from my network
from the network of people who were
sharing also because we like got uh many
people interested in like both like
speakers and later we were doing also
meetups uh for also women for girls and
women high school girls so and and then
like people started to get to me like i
really love what you're doing can we do
something like this in philippines can
we do something like this in luxembourg
can we do something like this in berlin
so can we do something like this in
vienna the lists go on so they really
saw that we are doing something cool and
they were like okay i like what you're
doing do you think you can share your
experience like you know and then they
wanted to start a chapter so people were
coming to us they really they could
relate to the problem you know that's
what i shared in the beginning that when
you when you uh become also when you you
feel that this is also a problem
many of our chapter leaders they are
mothers themselves working in tech
working in another industry
understanding the value of what the tech
industry can bring a part of different
community i was also that time
an active part of the drupal community
so and then also through that community
got in touch with different people so
community is so valuable and that's why
i also wanted to create a really global
community with uh with the current that
time was coding euros and currently it
was women tech network
what
what was the enabler that helped you
make this a successful organization at
scale was it simply that the problem was
was big enough was it the way that you
you know allow you know you helped these
other organizers to create chapters in
their own locations what really was the
catalyst for the scale here
in your opinion actually the both
factors that you uh mentioned are
relevant so people it's a global problem
problem it's not a regional problem
right
there is no country in the world but you
have like 50 50 you know but also
because it comes down to gender equality
some countries perform better but it's
like i think maximum 25
maybe in some european countries you
could have
going up to 31 or something like that
but it's like the numbers are still low
and there is still lots to be done you
know because of the thing that women and
their rights were suppressed for so many
years you know so they first they had to
fight for for studying at university for
example voting and for some countries it
even came later so they're still
fighting for for the change to come but
it's getting better and i think with the
help of technology nowadays especially
being able to connect from um from every
country in the world just you know
opening a computer and clicking just log
in into the conference platform and and
listening to all the talks i think this
is powerful
incredible so
let's transition then to the second
organization that you founded and we're
looking at women tech network and here
you've built a huge network of females
all around the world through events but
also through an online community where
you're empowering women to be to be
leaders what what is what was the
inspiration really tangibly to start
the women tech network so we started
women tech network it was pre-coded
times
uh so basically we were receiving from
both sides from our community requests
to help them find a job
at a company that you know would value
them for who they are would create an
environment where they could grow
and where they could feel that they
belong and on the other hand companies
also started to reach out to us and say
hey we we have a problem we understand
we have a problem we don't have enough
women we don't know why they don't apply
we would like to hire more women do you
think you can help us and we've been
organizing offline events in the form of
uh
networking speed networking where
companies and engineers developers
product managers could talk you know and
see whether there is a feed learn about
about different open roles and growth
and what company values and then we also
had inspirational talk so it was like
a mix of
inspiration and korea networking and
that was really great and everything was
going well and we had more than 50
events scheduled uh
like in in 2020 and then like it was
march uh beginning of march 2020 and we
had to really cancel them all
so and then
we were like okay
so we took
someone like a week off with my
co-founder to really try to understand
what we can do in the current
circumstances to continue our mission
because uh many communities were also
puzzled and they didn't know what to do
and they didn't know how to continue so
that's why like we we decided that we
are we are intact right so what can we
do with the help of technology and then
we thought why not to do the workshop
right
right and so
this the the really the founding you
know the first steps of of women tech
and you know
what was that really you know what was
the big challenge that you had to
overcome as you were just starting out
you know something that was perhaps not
trivial that you didn't expect
to happen in the beginning
i encountered so many challenges with
coding girls already you know this like
already been in the space uh helped me a
lot i
i i've heard different things like uh
different kind of
in the beginning with coding girls like
uh jokes can girls really code or i girl
i also heard something from
a woman who was running a female focused
organization not in tech but another
field and she was like uh oh you're you
know a millennial doing her like fun
startup thing you know different
comments from from different people you
gotta not take them you know otherwise
if you take them too close to your heart
they could really influence so deeply
you know and you need to make sure that
you have uh constant discussions with
the people who really need you and it
really need this the thing that you are
doing and um when you are also again
passionate about the problem and you
really know what you are doing such
things don't really touch you so deeply
but it's still not pleasant because you
understand that these people really
block the way for girls and women to go
and tag and this is not good right
because it's not really growing
it's not really it's not only helping us
it's it's another hair another hand
blocking us so yeah so if we're going 30
000 feet in the air and trying to
understand you know this global issue
and and how we solve it what are you
know
tangible ways in which we can begin to
reach
you know a more
equal world between men and women
especially in tech you know what are
some things that we should be really
cognizant of in your opinion
that i as a young entrepreneur anybody
listening here should take away from
this conversation you know in the
regards to bringing equality between men
and women in tech
first of all it's understanding that
there is an issue and man also should be
part of the solution if it's not your
problem then you could be part of the
solution and you should be part of the
solution then also understanding the
benefits of having more women intact
both for the performance of your team
for building better product for better
financial performance this is actually
proven also that moderate company
perform better financials or with
thousands of studies uh on this and i
think that when companies really start
mo we see that there is a positive trend
and more and more companies are starting
to recognize that and there is also not
enough tech talent so uh companies and
hiring managers they're trying to tap
into different pools of uh of of
different pools you know of talent and
trying to understand how they can um
grow the talent that they need you know
how
when they should start investing is it
schools at university how they can
support them better what they should do
um what kind of opportunities should
they offer like uh be it um maybe
mentoring program or be it in an
internship or being maybe uh maybe it's
from others who want to return to work
so kind of to really understand what are
the ways you can you can help uh women
and tech and what are the ways that you
can bring and grow you know motherboards
work for so they can again because and
not understanding that you're building a
product by let's say only man main
demand you are not building it only for
man right the world is so diverse we
have we have women we have uh gender
non-confirming so like
like we want to make sure that you keep
that in mind when you're building your
product
if you're looking at the last five years
specifically the last five years with
these two organizations what what you
know what are you taking away from that
you for yourself as the leader what did
you learn over the last five years that
you're saying you know what no matter
what i do next i'm gonna take these this
or a few of these lessons with me on my
journey
that's a really good question i never
really thought
from about this from this perspective
i think that i would if i you know if i
have to do it again i would have done it
with mistake that i made so like it's
worth the journey you know the the
journey that i had
i think some things were not uh the way
i imagined them to be sometimes when you
start you imagine more people to support
you or to kind of be able to be
sustainable faster so you need kind of
two it's like up and down up and down
and it's important that you have a good
support network you know whether with
your partner with your family or someone
could help you with children so you need
to make sure friends also it's important
advisors mentors your community so it's
it's important to
it's important to also ask for help i
think i in the beginning there were
moments when i
didn't really realize the power of that
and you kind of want to do it all
yourself to kind of prove that you can
do it right but it doesn't work this way
and i think we need to normalize that
thing a little bit in order to succeed
you need
you need to take it
you know they say it takes a village
so yeah it really takes a village
sometimes let's take a city maybe a
country yeah it takes a lot of effort
and i think people who make it look like
you know i did it myself only this is
not true there were so many people and
also i don't believe in the thing like
one person can can you know uh can do it
all can build it on on their own so this
is this is not true there are so many
people involved
in the process and i always tell it like
i am able to do what i'm doing thanks to
the great team thanks to my co-founder
thanks to the babysitter that comes
because i told you that i have a
two-year-old so um so there are so many
components you know that people don't
see behind the the maybe really good
looking picture and i think many people
try to even to make it even better you
know sound make it sound better look
better and there's so much
not real things on internet right now
and the thing that we're doing for
example with our global conference our
virtual events many of them are live and
uh all our talks at the global
conference the global awards are live so
none of them are like pretty coated or
something because we want to make sure
that there is this kind of
real time interaction with the audience
and i think people love that
incredible if you had to
look back at a you know look back at
yourself when you were younger what were
you really curious about what you know
what sparked a curiosity
in you as a kid
i was curious about so many things i
think general about the world i really
wanted to travel as a child i didn't
have that opportunity so there were
years in my life when i was like
traveling as much as i could and i think
i was traveling like maybe every week
every second week and i was like you
know i really wanted to to grab as much
as possible because i i also knew when i
you know when i was pregnant i was like
traveling to so many countries because i
wanted to make sure i make the most of
this time that i have because i knew as
a child it will be not so possible at
least not in this capacity so i really
wanted to
to
make sure i meet different people learn
about the culture learn about their
mentality talk to them listen to them
learn from them you know contribute to
that community for example as part of
the founder institute since we have uh
chapters almost in every every country
in the world so wherever i go i you know
just check out who is out there who's a
mentor who's a director just thought hey
i'm in the city do you want to meet up
for coffee you know stuff like that so
that also the power of being part of the
global network and actually was very
inspired by founder institute i joined
founder institute before i started
minimum tech network uh so and i was i
was very inspired by by the power and
the beauty of it that's why i probably
subconsciously also a little bit but
thanks to covet we also been able to
scale globally
and i i was also
you know we were also able to create a
very global and diverse network
i love it anna thank you so much for the
time and for your energy a really
really really appreciate it and really
appreciate that with just everything
that you're doing to the world into the
to the female community around the world
and you know
making it making women and men equal in
tech and i think that's such an
important mission and and and it's so
obvious the impact that you're having on
so many of the lives whether it's coding
girls or women tech network or anything
that you're going to do in the future
and everything else you've done in the
past so thank you very much for the
great work and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you
[Music]
you